you're watching like coming up on this
week's show the future of flight we take
a behind-the-scenes look at the jet
engines of tomorrow I'll be getting
under your skin with cutting-edge
holographic technology and we face off
against the walking dead and this week's
game didn't welcome to us like we've
come along to what's being billed out
the world's first Giants health event
the giant bit stands for global
innovation and new technology more on
that a bit later on but first I want to
tell you what alex has been doing this
week he's been given behind-the-scenes
access to wear rolls-royce is developing
the next generation of jet engines take
a look
the jet age it's made the world seem
smaller and trips to far-flung
destinations affordable with rouse /
airport expansion aircraft noise and
emissions demand is sky-high for new
innovations to make aircraft quieter and
more efficient and it's here in the UK
at their plant in Derby the rolls-royce
are developing the next generation of
jet engines some of the technology they
are looking ahead to here we won't see
in the skies for another 10 or 15 years
but already in production is the trent
xwb what designers claim is the world's
most efficient engine so when you look
at the engine you can see the huge fan
on the front and that pushes a lot of
cold air accelerates it around the core
of the engine where the engine is
complete as compressed and heated and
expanded and that cool air being blown
by the fan makes the engine quiet so if
you're on the ground and take off or the
aircraft's approaching basically much
quieter the efficiency is to do with how
we look after the air how we compress it
this engine takes in a squash court of
air every second and compresses it to
the size of a microwave oven it's it's
an incredible machine in terms of what
it's doing to the air but it's all
attention to detail and you know we're
proud of its got 38,000 parts of it all
of which we've got technology involved
with them and built here in Derby and it
will be it will maintain its status as
the world's most efficient engine for a
number of years to come building the
engine is one thing it then undergoes
thousands of hours of rigorous tests to
make sure it can withstand conditions in
the air whatever they might be looking
to the future and its new materials that
could hold the key making the blade out
of carbon fiber would allow them to be
larger and lighter impressive as these
developments are critics warn the pace
of change is lagging far behind the
scale of the challenge we need to find a
way of encouraging manufacturers to keep
pace with the enormous growth in in
aviation growth that's going to see a
three to four fold increase in the
sector's emission
so over the next few decades we need to
encourage manufacturers to think hard
about how we can have more continual
evolution and equally how we can
encourage airlines to purchase this
technology when it becomes available
given the rigorous testing needed and
development costs there's unlikely to be
a revolution in aircraft design for
decades instead little by little tweaked
by tweaked progress seems to be on a
slow but steady climb alex Morgan Sky
News stay with us still to come I'll be
going deep inside a human torso but it's
not as grim as it sounds I promise
that's coming right up after a roundup
of this week's tech needs a new
prototype supersonic airliner has been
unveiled which could take you on a
transatlantic trip in just three and a
half hours the boom aircraft backed by
Virgin Galactic could be seen in the
skies as soon as the early 2020s it's
one of a number of plans to bring back a
supersonic passenger flights a USB stick
and a drop of blood that's all you need
for a new HIV test developed by
scientists the process is similar to the
one here the disposable device detects
the virus and then creates an electric
signal your computer or handheld device
reads to get the result the whole test
can be complete within just 30 minutes
Google and Facebook have both announced
plans to crack down on so-called fake
news they say they'll target advertising
so website can't make money from phony
content
tougher rules are being considered to
make broadband adverts clearer so
consumers understand the real speed
they'll receive currently companies can
advertise feed that applies to only ten
percent of customers watchdogs warmness
leaves most people unclear about what
speed they'll actually gets and we had
to mention this week's supermoon in our
news roundup mainly because we just love
looking at the pictures people all over
the world share their perspective on the
largest lunar appearance in past sixty
nine years your father was an assassin
stick around for our games review we're
seeking revenge in Renaissance Italy but
first there's the whole load of
innovators and entrepreneurs here each
with their own high tech solution for
helping us improve our health we found
one exhibitor who's been using
holographic technology to help train
medical students come and meet dr. Javid
car hello you bought half a human body
with you that's right this is a
holographic 3d image it's human anatomy
and it's used to Train medical school
students at the University of Edinburgh
how has this become a tool for training
one of the problems faced by teachers of
anatomy and for the students is to
understand the complexities of the
internals of the human body this
includes things like the organs the
skeleton arteries this is very complex
information and a good way to show this
is in three dimensions so what are the
current methods for training students
would it be dissection and graphics
that's right currently students use
dissection which happens in later years
and they also use two-dimensional
atlases which is just like a book and in
fact we've made a three-dimensional
version of this Atlas which enables you
to see all of the human anatomy we've
imaged everything holographic technology
doesn't need glasses so things appear in
midair and this is a real plus for this
technology so you want those atlases to
be rolled out across universities then
that's right we're working on this now
together with a medical publisher and a
couple of universities I bet that's
going to be expensive though there must
be some drawbacks to this technology I
bet it costs a bomb
it used to be the case but the the
latest technology is is now
manufacturable and replicable so you can
copy it more easily so the prices have
come down significantly now time for our
games of this week we're running from
zombies and packing to beat state
surveillance here's Melissa this little
guy is one of the biggest technological
advancements of the last decade so it's
no surprise that game developers are
looking at it and thinking what can we
do with it in our game in what shocks to
has been turned into a weapon because
phones not only connect people together
they also connect technologies now it's
an open-world game so you basically have
the entire run of San Francisco itself
gameplay-wise it's all spiffed up in few
missions you've got your main storyline
missions that you can also go off on
side class the game really encourages
you to delve deeper into this world but
it's all based around the idea of
hacking you can hijack cars you can park
or around the city you can hack MPC
phones to steal their money or have them
arrested for crimes they didn't commit
you can also use a quadrocopter the
scouting and there are loads of stealth
based options all through the phone that
you have in your hand
we've seen quite a lot of last gen games
remastered for current consoles we've
got the by shock remaster just came out
there's the infinite warfare remaster
that's just launched alongside the new
call of GC and a batman remaster as well
so can top it all off we've now got Ezio
from the Assassin's Creed trilogy now if
you've not played this trilogy and
joined Assassin's Creed later in the
series perhaps with unity or black flag
I'd really encourage you to go and check
this one out Ezio is probably my
favorite protagonist that Ubisoft
created in this series so you embark on
this kind of quest through Renaissance
Italy and the history that they've
poured into this world is insane my some
of most standout moments are hanging off
the side of the Colosseum looking out to
glorious sunset over the fields and you
actually meet as well Leonardo da Vinci
a younger version who helps you out in
your quest so if you're a history buff
if you love open wild games definitely
recommend you checking them out
The Walking Dead is back on our screens
but i'm not talking about season seven
and Rick Grimes I'm talking about the
walking dead a new frontier this is a
telltale Game and telltale our
specialist funnily enough in telling
tales they do a lot of story driven
narrative games worth when you make a
decision your decision completely
impacts what happens later the
characters that you speak to the
alliances were forged for the third game
those reckonings of it as a new
character called Xavier in Step four
years after the first outbreak and you
play with him as past crosses with
Clementine so story details are fairly
scarce but if it follows the previous
Walking Dead telltale games you'll be
going through a world that's infested
with zombies you'll encounter survivors
as you go and you're going to have to
make decisions about who to trust who
not to trust who to save who to kill and
where to go in general you know every
decision that you make is going to
impact the story as it unfolds so it's
very much a playable TV narrative and I
personally love the telltale games I
think that they're a really interesting
example of how story time she's done
within games so if you're interested in
that to go check out
well that's it for this week if you
enjoyed watching this episode on't
forget you can watch any of our slides
episodes are no YouTube playlist just
type in my new swype and you can stay up
today with all the latest tech stories
on I news on mobile tablet catch up sky
cute and snapchat will be back next week
hope you can join us then bye bye